to live on earth is to live as part of a
network a giant web where almost every
creature depends on others for survival
these networks are so complex that it's
difficult to predict how resilient they
might be to changing conditions let's
take an ecosystem in Australia where
certain plants have a symbiotic
relationship with various ants the ants
acts as bodyguards protecting the plants
who in return provide food and shelter
for the ants but it's not like every
kind of plant has its own species of ant
that would be much too easy in fact each
ant can visit a variety of plants and
each plant benefits from the protection
of a number of different kinds of out
you can see how quickly a network
becomes very complicated let's take all
the plants in the ecosystem and draw
lines between any two species that share
at the same ants this ecosystem can be
represented by a network the plants are
the nodes and the connecting lines are
the ants two plants are linked if they
share at least one ant species if they
share more than one the link is even
stronger by helping the ants these
plants are also indirectly helping each
other the success of one plant might
lead to more ants which could benefit
another plant having lots of connections
also means the network can adapt to
change
for example along the bottom is a list
of all the out species in the system if
one of these ants disappears the network
can compensate its resilient up to a
point as we remove ant species at random
one by one the connections in the
network grow weaker and start to
disappear as we go along as well as
losing whole plant species the abundance
of remaining species gradually decreases
as well there comes a key point for
every Network where the population of
the remaining species suddenly crashes
the network can no longer compensate for
further changes
where this point comes represents the
network's resilience this resilience is
usually thought to be completely
unpredictable as it varies so much
between different networks but
researchers have developed a new tool to
try and simplify things they started
with complex multi-dimensional networks
all with different properties the clever
part is then using various mathematical
techniques to transform all these
networks into a standard model in which
the crash is always in the same place
this means that the resilience of the
original networks is now predictable
this can be useful in predicting how
ecosystems might react to environmental
changes climate change for example can
affect all species in a network and
their relationships weakening the
strength of all the connections this can
make the resilience of a network so low
that it might only take the removal of a
handful of species to bring about
complete collapse this is particularly
worrying for already fragile ecosystems
in which a tiny change could cause the
extinction of a whole host of plants and
animals that's why it's important to
have tools to predict and prevent these
catastrophic Network failures like the
disappearance of honeybees or unexpected
collapses and commercial fisheries and
these models don't just apply to
ecological systems the same tools can be
used to examine networks of people from
social networks to the spread of
epidemics banking networks in a
financial crisis and even networks of
air traffic which a single problem could
cause huge delays models of all these
things are often available ready based
on specific real-world data but these
new mathematical tools can be applied
generally to a whole range of different
systems they should allow us to predict
how any network will respond to change
and could even suggest specific
strategies for preventing catastrophic
damage
whether it's plants planes or people we
may be a little closer understanding the
giant complex networks of our planet
you